there's a burgeoning new online movement
billing itself as hashtag walk away
where once proud liberals denounced
their former political identity as the
left is moving further and further away
from something called reality but how
serious is this campaign the Washington
Post for one says this isn't
representative of some greater shift but
rather a figment of pro-trump social
media writing quote the walkaway meme is
what happens when everything is viral
and nothing matters joining us now to
respond to that calumny is the founder
of the movement brandon stretch i hey
Brandon how are ya hi Laura I'm doing
well how are you great to see okay I'm
gonna be devil's advocate okay that was
that Vica time great now this is Brandon
who's like your gay hairdresser want to
be an actor and now you're on TV yeah
are you punking us all am I gonna like
be he's like Ashton Kutcher gonna come
out and say you're Punk'd is it a big
punk thing it's 100 percent not a punk
thing I had a red pill experience in
2017 after the election of Donald Trump
as a matter of fact I welcome anyone to
go to my facebook page where I still
have videos up from 2016 at which I'm
crying because Hillary Clinton didn't
get elected I was devastated no this is
very very real so what is it about the
left today specifically that has made
you walk away you know what's so funny
is I created that video a few months ago
and a few months ago my biggest concern
was you know the the the nasty rhetoric
the the intolerance the the name-calling
the judgments that was just two months
ago and since this video came out we've
already seen a greater shift now I'm
actually worried about violence I'm
actually like it's already changed in
just two months
from where you know what my concerns
were just two months ago now I'm
actually worried that we may be on the
brink of it and incredibly violent out
you know episode now we also have had
the election of MS Acacio Cortes
Alexandria right in New York she beats
in this primary the number four guy in
the House of Representatives Joe Crowley
out of nowhere and this is how the she's
a about socialist this is how the head
of the
Emma Craddock national committee
describes her in this moment let's watch
okay the fourth most powerful Democrat
in the United States Congress
Congressman Joe Crowley was knocked out
by a young woman Allie's Alexandria
Ocasio Cortes 28 years old never ran for
office before she represents the future
of our party she ran a spirited campaign
future of our party yeah she obviously
is very young she thinks basically
everything should be free if you get
free college everybody's guaranteed
dignified health care I don't know
exactly what that is but right free free
free free free and apparently abolish I
so no no crackdown on human smuggling
child sex trafficking right
it's wild out there but she is the
future according to the Democratic
National Committee Chairman well I think
what they don't understand is that their
party has no future it's it's over and
that's exactly what this campaign that
I've that I've started the walkaway
campaign is is proving people are
leaving the left by tens of thousands my
group is growing every day by tens of
thousands and it's amazing because it's
actually happening on Facebook and
people are leaving testimonials we're
getting thousands of testimonials every
day that are either through video or
written word where people are talking
about how the the the left has become
intolerable to them they don't even
recognize their party anymore and what
do these people stand for I mean what is
their platform all I can figure out so
far is we hate Trump and we and we love
illegal immigrants and that's what else
is there now whatever you a Democrat
before Brandon I'm just curious what
what drew you to be a Democrat because
I'm gay I mean that's a lot of gay
friends who are not Democrats by the way
and and and people think they're bizarre
and well real that's real intolerance
toward them two of my friends who watch
every night you'll know I'm talking
about you especially but they get a lot
of craap from their pals I can tell you
that I'm sure yeah and I used to be one
of those people who would have given
them that but ya know I mean I just I
think that if you're a minority in
America if you're a black person if
you're Hispanic if you're gay there's
sort of this as some
that you are not wanted on the right
that you're not welcome on the right and
that you will be protected and cared for
if you go to the left and you stick with
the Liberals and the Democrats but we've
seen now that that's absolutely not true
they really take us for granted and
beyond taking us for granted they
actually forgave people have used our
fears and our traumas against us trying
to keep us in this constant state of
feeling like we're afraid or our rights
are in danger or the Trump
administration's out to hurt us and that
really upsets me
I want gay people I want all people but
particularly minorities in America to
note you have a choice you don't have to
vote Democrat just because you're a gay
person you don't have to vote Democrat
just because you're a black person if
you're a minority you have a choice and
that's what this campaign is about well
Brandon we really appreciate your
joining us and we welcome all people to
the conservative movement the Republican
Party and we're really glad you're out
there so thank you so much thank you so
much whether or not the walkaway
campaign becomes an actual political
force well we'll see